I have something to tell you all about
oh Jesus
after the last round table I was
recruited
to be a Trader
why I'm completely shocked I did not
know Christian would do that I don't
know if something happened last night
that I didn't know about I clearly said
no oh and I know this puts a massive
Target on my back I don't really care
what are you talking about like what are
you doing I don't know if anybody is
buying it is like cringe-worthy horrible
horrible acting this is like out of
control it is what it is now I'm really
uh a Target don't think Christian is
seeing the bigger picture it could
potentially put Targets on all of us but
he can't stop I was just like do I walk
me through that again what happened
there was like this like letter with
like a stamp thing on it going into
breakfast this morning I had a plan to
tell everyone I was recruited I know
nobody's getting murdered so there was
an opportunity for me to drop that car
just had two Christian you have been
invited to join our team because
um and it just said the faithfuls are
dwindling and then it was like do you
accept the other Traders are gonna be so
pissed however this buys me cover I
prove everyone I'm a faithful which I
figured would guarantee a pass to the
final day in the castle and hopefully
win this money I didn't really think
about it but I was like this is the
easier route is to just go with the
Traders yeah but I was like I can't can
you think he's lying I think every group
they recruited Christian he says he said
no but then he said a bunch of other
things
that's like huh
come on pause on